though we may keep a little quiet about
this especially when young we tend deep
down to be rather hopeful that we will
eventually manage to find perfection in
a number of areas we dream of one day
securing an ideally harmonious
relationship deeply fulfilling work a
happy family life and the respect of
others but life has a habit of dealing
us a range of blows and leaving nothing
much of this array of fine dreams save
some shattered and worthless fragments
it's at moments of disillusion that we
might turn our minds to a concept drawn
from Japanese philosophy and in
particular from the Zen Buddhist
approach to ceramics over the centuries
Zen masters developed an argument that
pots cups and bowls that had become
damaged she simply be neglected or
thrown away they should continue to
attract our respect and attention and be
repaired with enormous care this process
symbolizing a reconciliation with the
flaws and accidents of time intended to
reinforce some underlying themes in Zen
the word given to this tradition of
ceramic repair is kin tsuki kin golden
tsuki joinery it means quite literally
to join with gold in Zen aesthetics the
broken pieces of an accidentally smashed
pot should be carefully picked up
reassembled and then glued together with
lacquer inflected with the most
expensive gold powder there should be no
attempt to disguise the damage the point
is to render the fault lines beautiful
and strong the precious veins of gold
are there to emphasize that brakes have
a philosophical merit all of their own
the origins of kansui are set a date the
Muromachi period when the shogun of
japan Ashikaga Yoshimitsu broke his
favorite tea bowl and distraught sent it
to be repaired in china but on its
return he was horrified by the ugly
metal staples that had been used to join
the broken pieces and charged his
craftsmen with devising a more
appropriate solution what they came up
with was a method that didn't
guys the damage but made something
properly artful out of it
consumables to the Zen ideals of Webby
savvy which cherishes what simple
unpretentious and aged especially if it
has a rustic or weathered quality a
story is told of one of the great
proponents of Webby sappy sin no Riku on
a journey through southern Japan he was
once invited to a dinner where the host
thought he will be impressed by an
elaborate and expensive antique tea jar
that he had bought from China but Riku
didn't even seem to notice this item and
instead spent his time chatting and
admiring a Braj swaying in the breeze
outside in despair at his lack of
interest once recued left the devastated
host smashed the jar to pieces and
retired to his room but the other guests
more wisely gathered the fragments and
stuck them together through kinsuka when
Riku next came to visit the philosopher
turned to the repaired jar and with a
knowing smile exclaimed now it's
magnificent in an age that worships
youth perfection and the new the art of
consumer Taine's a particular wisdom as
applicable to our own lives as it is two
pots the care and love expended on the
shattered pieces should also encourage
us to respect what is damaged and
scarred vulnerable and imperfect
starting with ourselves and those around
us
you
you